e
okay good morning welcome to the special
committee on housing it's 10 o'clock
we're going to get started we have a
couple public hearings today but and uh
exact session but the first thing we're
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
God
liy and justice for
all okay so starting with the first
public hearing we have sp48 I'm going to
call on um Grant bossy um representing
Senator R
richardi
welcome thank you Mr chairman good
morning chairman Alexander members of
the housing committee I am Grant bossy
from the New Hampshire Senate
introducing s sp48 on behalf of Senator
Denise rardy the Bill's Prime sponsor
this bill should look very familiar to
you is it is very similar to HB
1168 creating a committee to study the
effects of the housing crisis on the
disability uh community and hopefully
recommending policy solutions that can
strengthen opportunities for
Independents the Senate is scheduled to
approve HB 1168 next week but with an
amendment I would like you to note the
Senate HHS committee extended the final
reporting date to November 1st
2025 and added an interim report for
November 1st
2024 uh I would suggest you coordinate
with Senator bsel rather than pass two
overlapping but slightly different
studies into law if you have any
questions I can get them to Senator
rardy and make sure to get you an answer
Senator rardy thanks you for your
consideration and support for Senate
Bill 48 thank you thank you for your
bossy my only question is does senate oh
does Senator vardi support the bill as
amended in the Senate yes it it went
through with unanimous support it's on
the consent calendar everybody agrees
giving the committee an extra year we're
a lot closer to November 1st than when
we first heard the bill and that was one
of the concerns as well and the concerns
was giving them enough time but still
getting some information out by November
1st and then giving them until 2025 to
get a final report in so my only
question would be legislators that are
appointed to that committee that decide
not to run for re-election or reelected
are they still serving on that committee
uh they would be reappoint you would
fill any vacancy Poss new member if
those if those members weren't reelected
or didn't choose to run thank you other
questions see none oh I think that makes
per perfect sense okay thank you thank
Damon thank you Mr chair good morning
thank you so I just have a question in
comparing uh the Senate bill that you've
just introduced with House Bill 1168
which as you know is remarkably
similar um the Senate
Bill specifies studying the effects of
the 2008 housing crisis which seems to
be a narrower scope
than uh
1168 which doesn't
specify a specific Year date housing
crisis and the house version speaks to
the committee evaluating potential
remedies for increasing the supply of
housing that language is not in the
Senate bille so if you have any uh
information on those differences or if
the senator could get back to us about
that I think frankly I prefer the
language of the house bill okay I think
there were just differences in drafting
as the different sponsors put the bill
together they made slightly different
choices uh in how it was worded I know
the um the suggestion for the bill came
from some of the same stakeholders and
then they just introduced it in the
house and the Senate
they went through the process and came
out slightly different ways um which way
is preferable that's policy decision and
I don't get a
vote thank
you all right seeing none thank you
thank
you the only other speaker I have on
this bill is uh representative Kathy
stub
U good morning um thank you for um
hearing my testimony I will be extremely
brief um because you've heard me before
and um I I just wanted to let you know
that I support the um changes that were
made to my bill in the Senate and I
think having an extended time period
having an interim report for you know
low hanging fruit and then um a longer
study to determine some other ways that
we might increase the supply of
affordable housing for people with
disabilities um I also just wanted to
share with you um The Gap report from
the national low-income housing
Coalition um it it
outlines um what the problem is um you
know for every hundred people that make
um 100% of median income um and need an
apartment there are 103 units um when
you get down to 30% of median income
which are people that are on disability
or Social Security there are only 38
affordable units which means that they
would only have to pay um 30% of their
income for their housing there are only
38 units for every 100 people that need
them or 100 households that need them so
I just copied that off for you and um
I'm going to hand it out and um does
anyone have any questions for me thank
you other questions for
representative see you on thank you
thank you
okay anyone else wishing to testify on S
SP
408 all right seeing none I'm going to
close the public hearing and I guess we
have eight minutes so we'll be in recess
minutes
e
let started so I'm going to open up the
public hearing on S SP 527 call on um
Jenny Horgan who's speaking on behalf of
welcome thank you Mr chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
Jenny Horan I am the policy director for
the Senate Democratic caucus I am
introducing Senate Bill 527 on behalf of
senator suprus Senate Bill 527 is
relative to student housing it includes
a student housing Municipal um a study
committee as well as a policy statement
as out of the Senate sen Apprentice um
is very regretful that she wasn't able
to be here today um basically
overarching concept on this bill and the
reason she brought it Forward was
because of the great need that our
communities have to find affordable
housing for students for Workforce the
bill as it stands has a policy statement
that has to make it that makes clear you
know the intent of a collaborative
nature between universities and
municipalities in terms of building a
housing housing stock that is diverse
and works for everyone involved um
there's also a study committee that has
duties to look at housing options for
students in those communities as well I
know that there is a non- derain hearing
after this amendment Center Apprentice
you know certainly supports the Senate
position of the bill she has some
concerns of about the non- gerine
amendment I'm sure she'd be happy to
answer any questions that you may have
about the underlying bill or the non-
germine amendment I'd be happy to take
those back to
her any questions for Jenny Morgan uh
representative
Walsh y thank you Mr chair um do you
know why I'm looking at the original um
527 do you know why section Roman 6 was
taken out and actually turned into the
study committee instead because actually
I like the look of section six in the
original Bill better than I like the non
gerain Amendment so I know that in the
Senate hearing the senator spoke to that
idea she did bring forward the amendment
that was a replace all just including
that original policy statement and a
study committee she heard a lot of
feedback and concerns about that
enforcement language and decided to move
forward with the bill as it currently
stands thank
you other
questions represent Reed thank you and
thank you for my question um has the
senator given information about where
she would stand on uh if the non-gain
amendment was in addition to a study
committee instead of replacing it I can
certainly take that back to her and have
her get back to the
committee um I just have a brief
question this is creating another study
committee to study like a solution to
the student housing problem in the state
but then the non-gain amendment is a
policy solution to deal with the student
housing problem in the state I guess I'm
wondering if the senator do we just want
to study it study it and study it or is
the senator infavor of like making
movements to actually solve the problem
I I think the senator as well as the
entire Senate is very invested in
finding actual solutions for problem but
as currently stands the study committee
is the Senate position on on the bill so
I can certainly take that back to her
but I would say that she supports the
bill as it currently stands okay I have
seen a lot of study committees come from
the Senate this year that's why I
ask sure of
course all right thank you very much
your testimony thank you very much
anyone else here to testify on sp sp 527
not the nonr
amendment just the underlying
Bill okay so seeing none we are in
10:30
e
just waiting for um my Democratic
colleagues to come back in the room and
started
e
Welcome Back special committee on
housing I'm going to open up the um
actually I'm going to let representative
arudy run this public hearing um because
I am on the
amendment non- gerain Amendment um so
chairman
Broody thank you Mr chairman you want to
read into the Min Amendment or introduce
you want to sit here or out there oh I'm
representative pow oh there's a whole
bunch of
people so you want to introduce it from
out there and then we'll no I'm I'm just
gon to ask questions oh you're going to
okay
thank you Mr chairman and honorable
committee members I appreciate the
opportunity to introduce to you today
Amendment 1482 to Senate Bill
527 for the record I am representative
Diane power I represent the towns of
Brookline Mason and Greenville in
Hillsboro County District
36 to begin this amendment is largely
based upon House Bill
1281 relative to zoning restrictions on
residential rental property which has a
strong bipartisan support in the house
and the Senate and it was filed upon the
request of a large group of concerned
citizens notably House Bill 1281 was
originally referred to this committee
but was vacated and assigned to
Municipal and County government at the
behest of the chair of that committee
the bill then was strategic allowed to
be tabled in the house now this
amendment is straightforward Common
Sense legislation which simply prohibits
municipalities from enacting and
enforcing zoning ordinances related to
the occupancy of any single family
duplex or multifam dwelling based on
familial or non-familiar re
relationships or marital status among
the occupants or restricts the number of
occupants to less than two per
bedroom additionally this amendment is
the product of months of collaboration
with colleagues on both sides of the
aisle Municipal attorneys from across
the country housing Advocates and a
number of citizen groups here in the
state the New Hampshire youth movement
as well as the New Hampshire University
of New Hampshire Senate to a
few this legislation is needed in our
state because I have found that there
are at least eight
municipalities with zoning ordinances
that unreasonably limit the number of
unrelated people allowed to rent and
occupy a residential dwelling
unit in fact some municipalities
arbitrarily restrict the N this number
to no more than three unrelated people
regardless of the size and number of
bedrooms in the housing unit this is
commonly referred to as the three
unrelated rule under this particular
type of ordinance it would be illegal
for four unrelated young professionals
students or even senior citizens to live
together in for example a four bedroom
rental unit whereas at the same time
a family of eight with two married
adults and six children would legally be
permitted to live in the same four
bedroom unit thus in this example one to
five housing opportunities are
eliminated by such unreasonable zoning
ordinances as we see in the three
unrelated rule in the midst of a housing
crisis zoning or ordinances like this
are highly problematic for a number of
reasons first and foremost overly
restrictive zoning ordinances are a
clear infringement by the government on
property rights of individuals to freely
utilize their private property property
in a reasonable and responsible manner
that does not pose any genuine health
and safety concerns furthermore I
contend that if the basis for such
ordinances are truly related to health
and safety then it would logically
follow that any occupancy restrictions
on residential housing should be equally
applied to all residential property
within the town significantly these
overly restrictive zoning ordinances
apply only to unrelated rental
households and not not to related
households even more problematic I found
that for example in the town of Durham
in which zoning ordinances restrict
unrelated households to no more than
three unrelated occupany occupants this
does not equally apply to all
residential rental properties in the
town as some properties are
grandfathered from this three unrelated
rule second over reaching zoning
ordinances that go beyond health and
safety negatively impact the
affordability and the supply of housing
in the granite state by arbitrarily
restricting the use of available housing
it is an indisputable fact that New
Hampshire currently has an inadequate
supply of affordable housing and a
Severe shortage of rental housing in
general make no mistake restricting
zoning restrictive zoning ordinances
drive up rental costs and it reduces the
number of available housing units which
further comp compounds our housing
crisis third restrictive zoning
ordinances are unfair to say the very
least as a result of the three unrelated
rule I was told by a property owner that
he had been accused of racism and
discrimination towards four unrelated
black men who wanted to rent one of his
properties to be clear the property in
question could have easily accommodated
these four men the men understandably
became very upset when the property
owner explained to them that he would be
unable to rent his property to these
four men due to a local zoning ordinance
that restricted the rental occupancy to
no more more than three unrelated
people because the men became became
upset because they knew of a house in
the very same town that was being rented
to eight unrelated Chinese restaurant
workers and fourth restrictive zoning
ordinances artificially limit housing
opportunities for people seeking
housing understand there are many
reasons for which unrelated individuals
might seek to share housing for example
college students might want to share
housing to be able to afford the cost of
room and board and
tuition working Professionals of all
ages might seek to share housing in
order to reduce expenses and to be able
to pay off their college loans others
find themselves in difficult
circumstances such as persons widowed
divorced or retired people living on
fixed or low incomes people who have
downsized or who are experiencing loss
of employment and the elderly and the
disabled are but a few examples that
come to mind these groups of people may
choose or even need to share housing
costs and expenses in order to avoid
homelessness finally I will make one
last important Point New Hampshire is
not a home rule state it is a Dylan's
rule state therefore a new hampsh in New
Hampshire a local government's Authority
is derived only from the power granted
to it by the state
legislature and importantly the power to
amend such local Authority is in fact
reserved and fully retained by the state
legislature as such under RS a 674 colon
16 municipalities have been granted the
power by the legislature to both adopt
and amend zoning ordinances for the
purpose of promoting health safety or
the general welfare of the community it
is clear that the power to adopt zoning
ordinances is being
unreasonably used by some municipalities
in a manner that blatantly is
overreaching and extends well beyond the
express objectives set forth in statute
as is evidenced by such zoning
ordinances as the three unrelated rule
therefore it is an incumbent upon our
state legislature to intervene on the
behalf of its
citizens and to amend the powers it has
granted to these municipalities
fittingly this amendment revises RSA 674
col Grant of power relative to zoning in
order to provide the appropriate guard
rails to local zoning powers granted by
the state legislature to
municipalities In Sum this amendment
upholds the inherent rights of property
owners guards against unfair practices
and unwarranted discrimination towards
unrelated people seeking housing and
helps to lower rental costs for granite
Staters by immediately increasing the
housing Supply when currently unused
housing is placed back onto the free
market therefore I urge this committee
to adopt this amendment and to
subsequently recommend Senate Bill 527
ought to pass as amended Mr chairman
that concludes my bill introduction I'm
happy to answer any questions however in
the interest of time I see there are a
number of people behind me so perhaps
questions could be tailored um to to the
people behind me
um um and I'd like to thank you for your
time and your consideration well thank
you but does anyone have a question
directly no okay representative Walsh
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question um I mean it's clear what
some of these ordinance are doing trying
to prevent frat houses in the middle of
their neighborhoods
perhaps in your your your examples some
of them may have gone too far or may
sound kind of
unreasonable so if we adopt this
amendment um I don't see any guard rails
in it to prevent 24 people from living
in a three-bedroom 26x 40 Ranch what do
you think is reasonable for the amount
of people living in a 2640 ranch with
three bedrooms so as a St stated in in
the
amendment I I have specified
that there's no local zoning ordinance
shall restrict the number of occupants
to to less than two per bedroom
depending upon the size of the bedroom
in question it is reasonable to be able
to house two people per bedroom now that
being said that would be you know up to
the landlord and the people
renting the both those groups those
parties may not be
interested in having two people per
bedroom but we want to be able to have
the flexibility and to be clear I'm not
interested in animal houses that that's
not what this amendment is is
about
and there are
other when you get to to more I with
regards to boarding
houses I honestly don't recall if that
threshold is four or five but at that at
that point then there
are codes building codes and fire codes
that that would apply and so I I would I
would contend that those are guard rails
to to to your concerns okay all yes
follow up thank you Mr chair um actually
the Animal House I'm glad you brought
that up because that's actually what the
ordinances are trying to prohibit so let
me ask you a question though uh because
I don't see a definition of bedroom
either so say you have a 26x 40 ranch
with three bedrooms uh is there anything
to prevent turning the dining room into
another bedroom and turning the den into
another bedroom in other words when does
this stop when there's a dozen 60 people
living in a house what could possibly go
wrong thank you representative I
appreciate that question so we we we we
know based on the assessment cards for a
particular property we can pull the
assessment card and we can
see you know the number of bedrooms so
that to me that would be a guide as to
how many bedrooms are are in a
property I'm not going to believe it you
can change anything you want
okay anyone else representative Reed
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for your testimony I find
it to be very compelling um in addition
to the points that you have very clearly
spelled out um do you think that if in
fact these uh local ordinances are meant
to address unsavory behavior in a
community for example that it makes more
sense to perhaps have ordinances to
address the actual behaviors for example
a noise ordinance and enforce those
ordinances rather than kind of
arbitrarily um limiting occupancy for
one type of Housing and I think maybe we
could get to the same place if we simply
said a municipality may not have an
ordinance that limits o occupancy on the
basis of whether a property is rental or
owned because you if you're going to
have an occupancy ordinance it should be
across the board but do you think that
it makes more sense to control the
behaviors that are unsavory rather than
than uh arbitrarily controlling
occupancy thank you for the question
representative that that's an excellent
point and I agree with um you know your
assertions clearly there are
ordinances on the books in
municipalities which deal with those
types of concerns with with you know
noise with parking with tracks
Etc what I have what has come to my
attention that restricting the number of
occupants to three that this three
unrelated rule is another attempt to
control those types of of concerns which
to me is highly inappropriate and it
doesn't make any sense because it's
infringing upon property rights of
individuals
a municipality doesn't have the right to
to do
that the constitution provides for
property owners to be able to utilize
and enjoy their property in a
manner that that's that's reasonable and
municipalities that have adopted such
ordinances are those ordinances are
overreaching and they infringe
um upon those rights and it's
inappropriate and like I've St stated
that when when we see this happening
it's incumbent upon the New Hampshire
General Court to to step in and and to
situation followup thank you Mr chair
and thank you again um in addition do
you think that uh it's possible to
interpret some of these ordinances that
restrict on the basis of related status
um in addition to all of the
Discrimination you've already kind of
put out that it could be a kind of like
moral legislating on the part of the the
town for example you know it's fine for
you to live in the same bedroom if you
are married but if you are simply dating
we don't want you in the same bedroom
thank you for the question
representative yes that you know that
that that that that could be the case in
in some instances for these types of uh
for these types of ordinances and in
fact
um in my work on this bill I I have in
fact um learned of a situation where to
unmarried individuals who were in a
relationship were denied the opportunity
to rent housing for the very fact that
unmarried okay anyone else Mr chair
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um you mentioned
boarding houses and were you referring
to roing
houses um thank you for the question um
yes yeah because rooming houses
um the single room that the person lives
in is their that's their domicile and
they have a locking key so it isn't like
because there are 10 rooms you know
rented in a rooming house that that's
over overly over occupied so it's one
person per unit or two people per unit
whatever this would not apply to that to
to those um types of of residences okay
thank you okay that it okay thank you
thank you Mr chair and committee members
for taking my testimony I'm Al Holland I
represent straford 20 which is Durham
Lee Madbury in a sliver of Dover um I've
spent uh in from 2016 to 22 on the
Durham Town Council and I'm currently on
the Durham uh advisory housing task
force where we used invest New Hampshire
money to do a housing needs assessment
of our community um so as uh this
similar Amendment came through the
municipal County uh committee there was
one community that was really talked
about almost exclusively and that was
Durham and Durham is unusual uh in the
fact that I I did demographically in the
State uh 18 to 24 year olds make up
about 99.1% of the population in Durham
it's about
66% which really speaks to what we are
which is a college community and it's
let me just say even despite what the
testimony was in Municipal County it's a
great place to live um our issue really
has been that UNH does not provide
enough housing for their students and we
currently house about
4,54 students in off-campus
complexes and the difficulty that we
really had came about from uh non-owner
occupied single family units that had
been bought by investors and used to
student housing and we had real
difficulties uh as investors came in and
these became nuisance houses uh I think
it was referred why don't we address
what we do of course we have noise
ordinances we have trash ordinances we
have a community policing officer that
came in but it takes an extraordinary
long time as you work through the fine
system and finally the court system to
deal with it and the neighbors suffer
and so what Durham did is uh we in fact
changed our zoning and it was actually
more liberal than the amendment asks for
and and I think the question was raised
what is reasonable in State Fire code
it's 200 square foot per occupant you
don't use bedroom because as was
mentioned you can get pretty creative
when you try to think about what a
bedroom is and so what we did is we
picked a zone that was best suited for
student housing right around the campus
and we gave great density bonus which
was 300t per occupant no related unrel
involved just per occupant and we built
2,000 units of student housing and it's
worked really really well it's close to
campus they're well-managed and we've
had very little problems with it
additionally in the collar uh zones
around it which was single family
housing we loosened the requirements for
uh adus and really made it uh um
enticing for homeowners to build adus
and we have 250 adus were built and
we've had absolutely no problems with
those the problems really have resided
still in those single family houses and
so let me clarify student housing
differs from regular rental housing by
the lease in the lease of a student
house uh it's uh less than a year which
kind of follows the academic calendar
which is what you see in dorms the
second thing is it's priced per occupant
so the idea that you would take a
one-bedroom and share it uh that doesn't
happen in any occupant is has a separate
lease and they're paying uh to the
landlord so if you have a house and you
put eight people in it all eight people
are paying to the landlord on a separate
lease and what we found in our housing
needs assessment is that actually drives
up the overall cost of the apartment and
that's boxing out both graduate students
who cannot afford the cost that
undergraduates can and our Workforce uh
so in terms of the three unrelated which
we did put in single family homes that
border that area it was not arbitrary in
fact that's based on fire code and so
when you look in the definition of fire
code when you move from three to four
unrelated and that's four to up to 16
and they share a kitchen it is no longer
classified as a single family home it is
classified as a lodging house and that
changes the fire code requirement of it
uh and there by the way in fire code the
unrelated and related is embedded in our
fire code what the fire code says is
that related people believe it or not
are more likely to care for each other
and so it lowers the overall fire risk
unrelated don't and so therefore there's
a higher requirement that's built into
fire code to address that you guys
change the legislation so that address
the sprinkler but it in the chapter 26
of the fire code there's a a greater
requirement for egress in that 4 to 16
lodging house and so as a community in
Ence what we said the three unrelated is
saying we as a community do not want
lodging houses to reside in our single
family uh our residential zones and and
so that's the the logic before it and it
seems to have worked really really well
I would also point out though uh we're
not the only college town in New
Hampshire Handover has also addressed
this similar issue particularly with
student leases and so what they did is
instead of doing the three unrelated
they broaden the definition of unrelated
which I have recommended by the way to
Durham uh by broadening the definition
of unrelated what they were really
trying to do is to strip off students
and particularly that student leasing uh
structure that really boxes out the the
identified groups that we really wanted
and not allowing that in certain areas
so we're we're zoning to put students in
and again we've put over 2,000 in and
having areas that really aren't the
prime area for students for residents
and Workforce outside of that
additionally what we've been working on
with new zoning uh uh is to try to do
Workforce overlay districts the
workforce overlay districts what we'll
do is we'll give density bonuses to do
Workforce housing in perpetuity uh our
housing assessment need identified zones
that are on Water and Sewer public water
and sewer and those are R to build more
Apartments uh the apartments that really
are better designed to deal with uh both
graduate students and our Workforce and
I think that was a lot of information to
throw pretty quick and I I hope I didn't
take too much time and and I'm open to
any questions okay any questions
representative Reed thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question I
appreciate that you said that you are
representing yourself and obviously your
district and not necessarily the Town
Council but I I have a question that I'm
hoping you'll be able to answer as your
experience on on the Town Council um so
from what I'm reading and perhaps this
is something that's already been changed
I'm reading something old but in your uh
ordinance you have under number four for
accessory
Apartments um an ordinance that
says uh in zoning districts where no
more than three unrelated persons May
occupy a dwelling unit there shall be no
more than three unrelated occup in total
for the single family dwelling unit and
an accessory dwelling unit combined or
for the single family dwelling and the
accessory apartment combined and um my
question is uh don't you feel that it
that conflicts directly I don't know if
the towns actually enforced that in
terms of three unrelated for an entire
property including the Adu and as you
know I'm very fond of adus and I
actually worked with your town Planner
on the Adu bill so I appreciate that and
I appreciate uh y'all's work in that in
the town on that but in existing law and
not my bill it actually says that the
municipality may not require familial
relationship between the occupants of an
accessory dwelling unit and the
occupancy of the principal dwelling unit
which as my understanding of
interpreting the existing law as I just
read it and your ordinance would mean
that if you had enforced that ordinance
that would have been an illegal
enforcement of that ordinance because
the state does not allow a town to
require an occupancy uh a relationship
between the occupancy between the the
primary unit and the dwelling the
accessory dwelling unit so are you
familiar with this conflict or has it
been enforced or is this changed already
um so that's a good question thank you
for asking it so uh to start off with
all the adus that we've had currently
are relatively small so putting three
occupants in would be a challenge this
question was asked of me though the way
if this goes through first of all the
Adu has not been signed by the governor
yet but if it did go through
um my reading of it would be that the
state uh the state would take precedence
and so uh the three unrelated would only
uh relate to each individual unit so the
Adu would have three unrelated the uh
primary uh residents theoretically could
have uh only three unrelated and again
that would only relate to single family
homes follow up follow up so I don't
know if I miscommunicated the the the
the section of law I read is not the
bill this is existing statute existing
statute prohibits a town from requiring
a familial relationship between the
owners the occupiers of the primary and
the Adu your ordinance as I currently
read it unless it's been changed and I
am not aware says that you can require
in essence through your three unrelated
uh occupancy rule you can require a
familial relationship essentially and so
my qu so just to be clear it's not a
matter of the Adu is going to be signed
or Not by the governor it is a matter of
current existing law and has Durham
broken the law by enforcing this
particular ordinance I'll give you a
simple answer no we have not it has
never been enforced okay representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question uh with your
permission Mr chair I have three
questions and I'll ask them one at a
time sure go ahead thank you uh okay um
my questions have to do with your
testimony and uh are also based on
personal experience from having lived
for five years in a neighborhood of
Brooklyn Massachusetts that was about
half students uh and have families um
and you mentioned that uh UNH doesn't
provide um uh enough housing for its
students which I'm sure is is uh uh
perfectly possible
um but even if UNH provided all the
housing that could reasonably be
expected wouldn't there still be some
students who prefer to live in rental
apartments so wouldn't that issue still
come
up uh so that's a good question actually
the the group that really wanted to live
off campus is graduate students because
uh the problem that the university has
is that Oyster River is a cooperative
district and so if a family of graduate
students lives on campus they have to
pay tuition to go into to Oyster River
School District and so uh the university
really believe me it really was and so
that it was really there was pressure on
the University because at one point they
were paying like $80,000 a year to the
school district for tuition and so the
University's response to that was to
tear down the graduate student housing
and to push them off campus and so there
clearly is a need for graduate student
housing uh in unh's expansion plans it's
all rests upon expanding their graduate
programs particularly their research
facilities but they haven't provided any
housing for them and as I said the uh
per unit rental model drives up the cost
and it boxes out those very students my
next question addresses that very
subject um and again I speak here from
personal experience
um the way it worked in the neighborhood
I lived in was that each apartment had
its own lease not each room not each
person each apartment and the leases ran
from September 1st through August 30th
so they were yearly leases not school
year
leases and uh the way it worked was um
one person in the apartment held the
lease and everybody else uh the other
three or four people however many it was
uh paid rent to the person who held the
lease who paid the rent to the landlord
couldn't that also be done in say Duram
and wouldn't that solve some of the
problems of RA raising up the cost and
having uh this odd school year lease
issue so yes that that would solve the
problem the difficulty is that as
municipality we don't have the ability
to enforce a lease agreement between a
tenant and and a building owner and so
the CR as I said the Crux of the real
problem that we're having is the leas
structure of that undergraduate housing
um and and we really are trying to work
around it ironically enough is we looked
at the workforce zones that we want to
build one of the groups that we've
identified that we really want are
healthcare workers and so uh UNH
students particularly those that have
lnas or LPN that are working their way
through uh the there's developers that
really want to build housing for them
because they need them to expand their
medical services and so what they do is
like they have a work requirement if
you're working for them that even
regardless of what any other thing
that's what really gets you into the
housing so the leasing really is as you
mentioned the Crux of the issue and has
the town uh has a town Administration
considered working with landlords to
change the lease structure to something
closer to a standard lease structure
that as you said would solve some of the
problems well of course it's investors
that are buying in and changing that
lease structure of course uh reduces the
return that the investor gets on his
property and so they really do not want
to do that actually we had a discussion
on the housing task force there is a
member of uh of a large rental complex
and uh believe it or not with declining
enrollment there has been an a softening
of the rent student rental market and so
the question is how do you convert those
right along your lease line how do you
convert those units back from the per
bed model to a traditional model to
actually capture again Workforce and
graduate student housing and so we don't
have a great answer to that yet uh last
question um uh you referred to problems
of noise and so forth with with student
housing uh and here again I speak from
personal experience um uh I'll just be
real real brief um the noise problem
where I lived did not come from any
students it came excuse the expression
from unhappy marriages we heard them
yelling at each other all night long so
my question is aren't there other noise
problems and other trash problems that
are not caused by
students for sure but not to the extent
of students uh I mean I I I I do not
want to sit here and Bash students
because they are a great part of Durham
and they make us what is special it's
really alcohol mixed with students that
creates a great deal of problems and uh
that demographic particularly is where
the issue lies um and that's why we also
implemented a community police officer
that when I mean again our our police
chief said you're not going to arrest
your way out of the problem and I think
that's we strongly believe we don't want
to harm people that are coming to our
community before they have a chance to
fully grow up and so uh the community
police officer what they do is the day
after they come they talk to the
students and work with them and again
the large complexes that are
well-managed along with the adus we've
had really no problems they've worked
out really well thank you representative
Alexander thank you Mr chair um earlier
you referenced nuisance housing can you
talk to me a little bit about what you
mean by nuisance housing uh well was
right along this noise uh that you know
unfortunately uh some houses run on a
different time schedule that families do
and so when it's like 1 or two o'clock
in the morning and you have a stereo
blasting that's the noise problem trash
I would welcome any of you to come to
Durham on a Sunday morning and take a
actually take a ride along with our
police on like a Friday or Saturday
night or come around Saturday morning
and look and you'll see there's like
beer cans strewn everywhere and a lot of
those uh those houses s are sitting
right next to a middle school so it
disrupts our Middle School um so I mean
that those are the two things that we
really have faced repeatedly and I can
follow up how long has UNH been a
school uh you know I I probably should
have that by heart at least 100 years
yeah so any family that decided to
purchase a a home near a school
understands that with the school comes
students I guess I'm confused with like
the property owner purchased the
property near the school they had to
know that that was one of the reasons or
one of the nuisances of buying a
property near school right for sure I
mean obviously when you move to Durham
you know it's a college campus but we as
a municipality don't say I'm sorry
you're out of luck the whole point of
like zoning is that you're supposed to
try to address issues that are occurring
and so what we tried to do is resolve it
by putting and by the way the other
thing that's lost in there is not just
nuisances it's student safety when you
mix alcohol and students there can be
some very serious cons consequences that
come along with it and so by putting
students in a more appropriate place
that are better supervised it it it
really is to the safety element of the
students and so again just saying I'm
sorry we didn't know that your property
would flood or that you'd have students
and and you're out of luck is generally
not the way that we try to work as a
municipality okay representative
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
helping us understand this um I have two
questions so first of all you spoke
about I believe Handover having a
broader definition of unrelated so what
is the definition of unrelated and or
what are the different
definitions so I I I'll have to have
send you the actual definitions but the
large part was it worked in the lease it
they somebody was there like you know um
12 months not 11 months and then again I
can't remember the the particulars but
in essence what it was doing was
stripping off that students from non-
students it's a little vague but I I I
mean again I I have to come back it
would be great if you could send it
thank you yeah and second question um so
this is a completely different
question I was puzzled by your statement
about Oyster River Cooperative School
District which is a public school
district charging residents of a
community in the District tuition do I
have that right you do have that right
so since it is a the the the issue is if
you live on University property the
university does not pay property taxes
to the municipality and since we're a
Cooperative we cannot say you know what
we're going to let this fly because Lee
and madbear would say well that's not
fair in the apportionment of the
students so so as a result that if you
live on private uh University property
the University is responsible for the
tuition clarification oh so just to
clarify or extend my understanding of
that
so employees or grad students or whoever
living on the UNH property who have
school age
children access public school because
the State University pays the tuition
and otherwise they wouldn't have access
to public school they would if they
lived off campus but if they live on
don't we learn something every
day okay uh representative Reed thank
you again Mr chair and thank you again
for taking my question I also by the way
um not related to my question directly
would like the definition of unrelated
because I was wondering the same thing
and I'm thinking well really aren't we
all related in in some way so uh our
larger family of man and I'm I'm I'm
interested in how that is defined but my
question is um and it's kind of a
two-fold question in my it's what is the
difference
between because as I hear you saying you
don't want to disparage students I'm
also hearing how all of these ordinances
are very tailored towards students and
restricting students and students are
the problem and students have worse
behavior and we're worried about student
Behavior whether it's you know you're
trying to get around the lease terms to
directly you know deal with the fact
that they are students or the you know
are they related to deal with the fact
that their students is all by admission
very much geared towards students that
demographic and so my question is what's
the difference between singling out that
demographic and singling out any other
demographic that might statistically
have different behaviors broadly
speaking for example what's the
difference between saying well we want
to Target students because they have
problematic behavior and we want to
Target a particular religion or a
particular ethnicity because they have
certain cultural behaviors because to me
it sounds a little cringe if you forgive
the expression that we are admitting
that we want to Target students a
particular demographic so what's the
difference so I I did mention that we
University Town right so uh so in a in a
University Town what if you ask students
where do you want to live
they want to live close to campus and so
uh again in terms of targeting students
we we built 2,000 units of student
housing we built the housing where
students wanted where best fit the
students and so uh that o we what we're
trying to do the idea is open up other
housing to the groups that we've
identified that couldn't get housing
regardless of ethnicity sex or anything
else you would put in there what we
really defining it it as is workers
graduate students people that could not
afford that per bed unit and so in
instead of like in saying that we're
targeting students or that we're trying
to uh you know hold off on that that is
actually the data doesn't show that that
is why we did build housing we built it
where it really fit where it worked with
the
university follow up thank you and I I
wasn't um at all uh casting aspersions I
was using your own words when you were
trying to explain what related meant you
said specifically you were trying to aim
at students in the ordinance that's what
you had said so that's why I repeated
that um my second part of this what is
the difference question is if you buy a
house as was mentioned uh in a student
town in a University Town you know that
you're buying a property and there's
students around that's going to be a
tradeoff what are the benefits to living
near a college and there are many
benefits to living near a college what
are the the the the con side how is that
different than buying anywhere else if I
buy a house in a rural area the pro is
it's a beautiful rural area the con is I
might have to commute further there may
not be as many services available to me
etc etc if I buy in a city just the
opposite the pro is I have lots of
services public transit you name it but
there may not be as uh much space so
what is the difference between accepting
the tradeoff and buying a different area
wherever you're going there's a
trade-off and buying in a university
it's a tradeoff you know the trade-off
when you buy that property what's the
difference so the difference is that uh
it's more difficult to buy a house where
we are because an investor will box you
out since the investor can rent per B
per occupant uh they're able to get a
really high return on it and so they'll
pay cash and you'll have difficulty
buying that house and so what we've seen
is investors have been buying up all the
single family houses that sit on the uh
the border of the university and that
really boxes out most homeowners from
buying them yeah well that's
all um and I do appreciate what you just
brought up because uh and this is very
broadly on on the housing issue in
general my point has been while we do
need to deal with Supply very
desperately um Supply Is Not the Only
Solution here because it Durham is my
example exle where it's been built it
hasn't necessarily brought down costs
Supply alone does not fix the problem
and I think you pinpointed a large other
piece of the problem which is investors
and what they have done in terms of
buying up housing so my question is does
it not make a lot more sense to Target
that behavior investor Behavior large
corporate landlord Behavior rather than
penalize the students by saying that
they can't live in a bedroom with their
whoever
so thank you for the question so that's
the beauty of the workforce uh overlay
District uh we can use density when when
an investor comes to us and we have an
investor that's really interested in a
117 acre parcel that would give us over
200 units and we can say to the investor
you know what we'll give you greater
density we'll push down that per
occupant square footage but in tradeoff
we're going to ask for a percentage to
be in Workforce for perpetuity and
that's better even than the invest New
Hampshire money that came in which is
only five years which is too short and
so the workforce opportunity clause in
79e is about 30% that it pushes in this
we're actually trying to go much higher
so so to deal with investers again uh
we're trying to use uh the carrot rather
than stick I guess is the approach okay
thank you representative
Gibbs thank you uh I guess this is is
really a follow follow up to one of my
earlier questions um and I have to admit
here that in spite of actually being a
lawyer I'm not sure how this would work
legally uh but it it occurs to me that
if you are able to control the number of
unrelated people living in a unit um
might it not be possible to control
something about the way leases work that
is that control how the lease would work
and the lease being per unit rather than
per bedroom or per occupant and that
again as you mentioned earlier might
solve a lot of your problems um well
that's a good question uh so again the
the the way that you're able to control
the occupancy really is by the
definition so uh four to 16 that are
unrelated that are sharing a kitchen
aren't it's not a single family house
anymore by definition in your zoning
table it becomes a lodging house and so
we're able to control occupancy because
we can able to control what we allow in
certain zones the least I I have to say
I'm not a lawyer so I cannot speak to
that okay well thank you very much uh
housing thank you Mr chairman good
morning committee members I'm Ben Frost
I'm the deputy director and chief legal
officer at New Hampshire housing I'm
here in uh to speak in support of the
amendment uh 1482 to Senate Bill
527 there's been an awful lot U said
about this bill I so I'll just make a
few additional points
um this is a question of means of
addressing an
issue
and I would submit to you that the way
that uh some communities are attempting
to address this issue is potentially
unconstitutional and probably uh uh
definitely a violation of state law
against
discrimination uh and I speak in
particular uh with regard to the
questions of familial status and marital
status um RSA 150 RSA
354a uh which is the states uh
anti-discrimination law addresses these
two issues and as well as a variety of
other classes of of peoples who are
protected against discrimination but it
says that um there shall be no
discrimination on the basis of familial
status or marital status and these words
um are either indirectly or directly
referred to in the amendment on line 15
um familial or non-familial
relationships marital stat stat uh it in
my view it is not the business of the
government including
municipalities to decide who should be
occupying a
bedroom whether they're unrelated or
married that is A Private
Matter uh when it comes to
discrimination there are exceptions so
there are bases for the government to
act in a discriminatory fashion if in
these cases where you have these
protected classes if there is a
compelling governmental interest
and there is not a less restrictive
means possible so maybe there is a
compelling governmental interest here uh
and maybe that's the safety of uh the
occupants of the structure or something
to do with the
neighborhood uh but there is most
certainly a less intrusive means
possible
and I think it has already been clearly
articulated here this morning that is
enforcement of the fire code the fire
code the state fire code RSA 153
addresses occupancy IT addresses how
much space people need to safely occupy
a dwelling
unit and if these towns that have this
concern would just do
that then I think they would find that
questions of overcrowding would be
addressed certainly they also have other
means to address the other issues waste
noise and I know that they are difficult
to enforce but that does not mean that
the difficulty of enforcement of those
measures does not entitle them to engage
in unlawful
discrimination under state law and
federal
law I'd be happy to take any questions
thank you any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you
well we do have a question
here thank you uh Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so um the
ordinances in um darm have they ever
been tested um around this
issue yes represent V Lorenzo I believe
that the Durham ordinance or at least an
earlier iteration of the Durham
ordinance was tested I think there was a
1975 case where uh I think it was
Superior Court found that the the
language that Durham was using uh
unrelated individuals and the standards
were different at that time in the
zoning ordinance uh did not afford
protection to the challengers uh because
they were resting on the F the the
familial status uh um protection and
they were not a family under under law
so they didn't get that protection this
language is much clearer uh in this
Amendment because it refers to familial
or non-familiar relationships and
marital status so um and I think it was
a representative power who gave a couple
of really great illustrative
examples um you know two unmarried
couples cannot live together in the same
apartment in
related uh followup so um um when I
think about um Family status um as per
HUD it's a family is a group of people
that want to live together to um you
know cohabit and and that's it it
doesn't talk about um you know
relationships so I'm I'm sort of like
drawing that as an analogy um to what I
feel um should be the LIE thank you I
agree
okay um Mr Frost what town do you live
in I live in the Town of Warner Warner
okay are you aware when you purchase the
prop do you own a property I do are you
aware that there's a college near Warner
and that you might have students living
near you there there was a college in
Warner it closed recently um and I'm I'm
I was certainly aware of it yes thank
you representative
Gibbs thank you um I I hesitate to uh
appear to contradict you on this um but
it happens to be an issue that um I'm
particularly familiar with and that
involves the definition of familial
status um uh under both state and
federal law
um and that is uh familial status I'm
looking here at the text of RSA
354a I have it here too representative
sorry I have I have it here too
representative um and it refers to
individuals who have not attained the
age of 18 who have not attained the age
of 18 years of age domiciled with a
parent grandparent or another person
having legal custody and it goes on uh
to cover someone who is pregnant or in
the process of of obtaining legal
custody um the point being that it
refers to uh families with children
rather than General familial status uh
the status of being unrelated now state
law also covers marital status which
federal law does that does not um so
that gives you a little more of a handle
there under state law but I just thought
it was important to point that out
representative gives a a agree with you
completely and I I had have read that
definition in RSA 354a and that's why I
think the inclusion of the term marital
status on line 15 is very important
thank you
okay thank you that's it thank you um
action and supported
Bill thank you representative barudi Mr
chairman members of the committee for
the record my name is Alyssa marglin I
serve as director of housing action New
Hampshire um and we are here in support
of um the amendment
1482 to Senate Bill 527 and want to
thank um representative power for uh
bringing this forward and her advocacy
on this important issue um this
committee has done a tremendous job in
documenting um the real uh suffering
experienced by Granite Staters due to
the housing crisis some of that
suffering has come through in testimony
because of struggles to stay in the
state as he young person other people
have talked about being the parent of um
adult children with disabilities others
have told you about um how business and
economic growth is suffering and this
committee has done a good job in
identifying uh legislative proposals um
to ameliorate the situation for our
state um the members of my organization
housing action New Hampshire are on the
front lines of this crisis they are
trying to problem solve this um they are
the developers they are the financers of
affordable housing properties they're
the Supportive Housing providers for
those uh uh those who need services in
addition uh to their housing um and they
are using every tool available that the
state makes available that
municipalities may make available to
solve this crisis when they are hitting
a
barrier where are they supposed to go
they are supposed to go to the lawmakers
to ask them for Relief to say thank you
for these tools however we are still
unable to provide this housing uh and so
are they are asking um for uh for you to
improve the law um so that they can help
solve a very serious crisis we view this
amendment as one of those places where
it's important to come to State
lawmakers in particular and while um the
efforts at many municip IES including
some of them mentioned today have been
impressive and a real commitment to
addressing the crisis there are still
places where there remains bias and
barriers in need of a state lawmaker
scrutiny and support and so um with that
we ask you to consider um making an
important step in this direction and
passing this of recommending it for
passage I do want to also name something
about home share for people aging or
desire iring to age in place New
Hampshire does not yet have a strong
home share program and in many times
it's because they're battling local
ordinances like this one they would like
to create um programs where um people
who are unrelated could help an aging
person stay in their home um and there
are examples in other states where this
has been successful our attempts yet New
Hampshire um are kind of non-starters
and I think that passing this would be
important foundationally for helping us
uh launch some of these home share
programs in the state and with that I'll
conclude okay thank you any
none
um n Graves from uh New Hampshire
Municipal
Association thank you Mr chair and H
Grace for the municipal Association uh
we we doose this legisl or this John
gerain Amendment um I do want to note
because I know some of you also serve on
Municipal County government and that
when the original bill um House Bill
1281 came up we did not have a position
on that bill however we were provided
further information from affected
communities including Durham who who
you've heard about extensively today um
as well as Lebanon and Handover all of
whom have submitted written testimony as
well and as a result we uh uh we are
opposing this non-main amendment um I do
want to note that I am not familiar with
the particularities of Durham's zoning
ordinance or how that interacts with
state law I am aware that the town
planner is sitting behind me waiting to
testify so I would ask to defer
questions to him if you have those
specific questions um I just want to
note um that you know this this is this
would be a Statewide mandate that would
that would overrule the decisions of uh
local communities you've heard
extensively uh from Durham about how
they have attempted to um balance the
interests of various parties within
their Community um I understand that not
everyone agrees with how they've chosen
to do that um but it is important and I
think that the very extensive testimony
illustrates that these are very
complicated issues um that don't have a
single solution um that obviously
require a lot of input uh a lot of
thought and Durham has clearly done that
um as a result they have created a uh a
series of
ordinances um that interact that attempt
to balance the interests of of who needs
housing in their Community promote
housing in a way that uh allows kind of
equity across the board um and that's
what we've seen in other communities um
with other uh with other definitions and
other um variations of this
um and that's that's exactly what we're
talking about when we're talking about
um you know uh non non-permanent uh type
of housing as for students um and so
it's it's really more appropriate to
deal with that at the local level as
they can tailor that to kind of the
needs of the individual communities both
the res both the permanent residents
coming forward as well as the colleges
universities other um student based uh
entities and uh and talk about what will
work what can be supported by those
entities as well as what's needed from
the community and have that free flow of
information rather than putting in place
a Statewide mandate that is going to
force um significant changes uh to a
number of communities across the state
happy to take any questions that the
ghouls we have your written testimony
here thank you I may digress a little
bit just listening to some oppos a bill
to other testimony but uh thank you for
listening to me members of the
committee um my name is jayg I've lived
in Durham since
1978 uh actually 77 but I live in the
same street since 1978 and it is is very
close to proximity to everything with
the
university uh I walked downtown now I
took a two-mile walk all around the
campus this morning so I'm very familiar
with being close to the campus I was a
volunteer physician for the hockey team
for 40 years uh retired a few years ago
from that and
I have very good friends who were
students some of them still contact me
after all these years so I'm a fan of
Hampshire but I am test testifying today
in opposition to the amendment that was
added to Senate Bill 527 concerning a
minimum of two renters per bedroom this
amendment I do not believe is an
effective way to deal with New
Hampshire's affordable housing problem
and I'm really hoping at the end of my
testimony you'll take into consideration
that we are trying and Durham to address
this issue and to do it this way would
tremendously impact and I'll explain why
Durham by the will of the people placed
reasonable constraints on the number of
renters in our single family homes when
I first moved to Durham many single
family homes were owned by faculty of
the university and the local school
system because it was affordable to buy
and live in those houses shortly after
my family moved here investors found
that buying houses and renting to as
many University students as possible
provided an excellent return on their
investment especially if the investor
minimized maintenance and upkeep
expenses soon home afford home
affordability for families began to
disappear as the landlord's renting by
the bed could outbid families for the
properties once a house in the
residential neighborhood became a
student rental now I can use this term
student rental I was involved with
drafting the ordinance in 1986 for the
three unrelated and I was very
specifically told by attorneys don't say
student you've got to make it general
for unrelated because you can't
discriminate against students so I'm a
little bit confused about seeing this
amendment which
specifically targets
students
so for years we were told we could uh
could not say students but it resulted
than parties cars noise and trash issues
that ensued after these homes were
bought by these investors one of the
many and I'm going to get personal one
of the many examples of this was when
the house across from us was rented to
five students while my daughter was
recovering from major lung
surgery constant noise related to the
lifestyle of students ensued calling the
police for ongoing problems of drunken
shouting and car door slamming at one
123 am did not help as often the issue
ended before the police arrived leaving
my daughter and US Disturbed throughout
the night other residents our
neighborhood were dealing with drunk
students trespassing near their house
while shouting urinating and worse again
calling the police did no good because
try as they might to be
helpful the perpetrators had moved on
once the house across from us was deemed
to fall under under our ordinance it has
been occupied with one owner or a family
in the main house and one to two
students or a family in the Adu there
have been no problems with this
Arrangement students living in Durham
for two to three years do not have the
same behavior or lifestyle of working or
retired full-time
residents when I was on Our Town Council
I served on the Regional Housing
Commission that met in Portsmouth over
the course of two to three years no
matter what plan we came up with the
answer for Durham was always the same
investors could outbid families for
homes because of their ability to rent
by the bed at the higher Market rates
driven by the
university while committed to our
families and neighborhoods Durham has
been equally committed to increasing
housing for our student residents over
the past 15 years our zoning and
planning processes have allowed the
number of student residents to increase
over 130% by adding new well- managed
departments that can accommodate almost
students this amendment will not help
affordable housing in Durham or the
region in fact it will do the opposite
by taking affordable housing stock off
the market for families and placing it
in the hands of investors when upper
classman at UNH prefer the
interdependency of living off campus
Durham Apartments accommodate them with
well-maintained and managed options that
compete for their business these are
part of what we have built in the last 5
to 10 years the University's new
requirement that freshmen and sophomores
live on campus next year will place more
pressure on their professionally managed
departments and that puts pressure on
Durham landlords that have invested over
100 million in Durham housing and that
is why this amendment has been
introduced this amendment will not make
housing more affordable but rather make
renting by the bed in single family
homes attractive to investors while
displacing families from our
neighborhoods thank you for that part
I'd like to just add a couple of things
because of what has been testified to
someone said why would you come to UNH
if you knew it was this it was a
university you knew there was going to
be problems but when we came all the
houses near the Middle School were owned
by faculty or owned by just regular
residents all along from where I live to
the hockey rink six houses were all
family-owned over the cast of the next
five to six years those houses became
bought by
investors and they put in at that time
could that was why we had to find
something to do and the three unrelated
rule at the time that we did it was
legal now whether or not it would be now
I can't tell you it's never been
challenged now but it did get challenged
in the white case which I think was in
77 or 78 and at that time they
specifically referenced the US Supreme
Court and belter versus baras in
1974 that specifically said it was legal
for
residents to limit occupancy to
unrelated I unrelated you can look it up
if you like it may not be relevant now
it hasn't been challenged since but it
was legal when we did it and we were
legally the other thing is any investor
who has come into Durham since the
ordinance was done has known about this
ordinance it was their choice to come in
knowing that they were going to be
restricted in terms of what they could
rent you so they have complaints now
disingenuous um so I guess that's my
testimony you're welcome to answer any
answer any questions thank
you representative Gibbs yes ma'am thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question this goes back to some of the
comments that we had earlier um might it
not be possible to solve the problems
that you describe by controlling the
investor Behavior rather rather than
controlling the relationships of the
tenants and specifically by requiring
that the in that the investors the
landlords rent per unit rather than per
bedroom as far as I know we've certain
we had a rental Housing Commission that
I was a member of when we had certain
landlords that were in that uh committee
I guess a town committee uh along with
some of the people in the administration
in the town and I I think if those
things were mentioned the landlords
would have no part of it I don't think
legally I'm not sure exactly but
somebody could tell me I'm not think
that we can legally require them to have
a certain type of
lease I know we had difficulty even
trying to have inspections done because
it for the safety of the people renting
we tried to work on that for years and
we were fought all the time by the
investors by the the owners so I can't
answer your question as to what I know
we've tried to do everything we can I
can't answer the specific question thank
you you're wel okay thank you yes ma'am
representative D dzo thank you Mr chair
and thank you for take my question so
speaking about the investor units what
what kind are they I mean are they
buying single family homes and
converting are they you know stacked
buildings or no just regular s single
family homes and typically they might
have an Adu with
them um and you know this has been one
of the many things we have tried to do
in the town to control our just normal
living like any one of you people here
would not want to be woken up night
after night at 2: or 3 in the morning by
people just walking by your house
shouting generally
inebriated it didn't used to happen when
I first came and we have it relatively
well controlled now we have a tremendous
police force who will
come out when they need to we have a
community officer who will go and talk
to the houses when there's problems of
course next semester it's like deja vu
all over again same thing
happens and
uh so this is just one part of the
armentarium of trying to deal with it
may I follow up please follow up so how
many investor units do you think there
are in durm how many investors how many
investor units do you think you I don't
have that number maybe our planning
director has it or our code enforcement
officer I think something like
805 by 90 I believe I saw that number 85
by 90 investor units yeah I mean it may
be more uh there's a lot of students
living we have a seven houses in our
street and I think four of them have
adus with students but the owners live
there so follow up again um so when you
look at Deeds
um in your property tax roles are the
investors identified as Xyz Inc or
something like that or we can't make
them commercial they have to be just
residential so they're so they are taxed
as
residential right as a certain number of
bedrooms but they
rent by the bed but are there particular
llc's or corporations that are buying up
these places uh there's three or four
landlords that may have more two or
three units okay
yes it isn't so it's really not easy to
identify as a widespread no and you
never know which one's going to go I
live in fear and I when this was first
proposed I really said to Our Town
Administrator if this happens again and
there are five or six like we across
from me before I will
move I cannot live with that no none of
you could
okay thank you thank you representative
Damon I'm wondering if um thank you and
thank you for taking my question I'm
wondering if there has been any
consideration or perhaps experience of
the
Town becoming the investor and the
landlord I think everything has been
discussed and if we're not it's because
perfect so not affordable to buy it
right
thank representative Alexander thank you
Mr chair I'm um thank you for taking my
question your testimony I'm concerned
when you say normal living because
Normal to me what I do at night like I'm
a bartender so I come home from work at
1100 p.m. and I might decide to have two
or three drinks and then by the time you
know it I'm in bed by 2: a.m. and you
know people that know me know that you
really can't contact me before noon if
I'm not you know like sure would that be
considered normal living that concerns
me when you say normal like it's just a
different lifestyle I'm talking about a
different lifestyle you you have to
understand that you come home and you
usually because you're in the
neighborhood sure you might have had two
or three drinks but you're not going to
come in and shout and scream and no
typically you won't I don't think so
anybody would want that in their
neighborhood guess know if you do sir
but most people living in the
neighborhood would be upset if that was
going on in the neighborhood and that's
why we're upset when it my concern is
have these students at all violated the
health and safety of your own
property at all have they violated your
safety they VI violated my
health okay I I'm going to leave it
there I know okay my mental
health okay thank you
um okay thank
you okay yeah thank you very much
Michael Barr is the uh Durham Town
um to The Honorable members of the House
special committee on housing um thank
you for the opportunity to
speak um I am speaking in opposition to
the amendment proposed for S SP
um
um I am the town planner for Durham um I
have over 30 experience in four
municipalities as a professional planner
uh and a lot lot of experience with
housing um this amendment would have
very detrimental impacts on the cities
and towns in New
Hampshire that host colleges and
universities and on the neighboring
communities um I see no benefits from
this bill uh to the public um the
benefits would would all ACR to a
handful of
investors um who would uh have therefore
be able to cram
um that's a word you hear a lot in town
cram more undergraduate students into
single family houses rather than three
four five six sky the limit um and make
a lot of money make a huge return um at
the expense of the neighborhood um
please keep in mind that within
neighborhoods single family and some of
them are mixed they have single family
they have some duplexes a lot of adus we
love adus in Durham um because it's
usually one student or two and the owner
lives on the premises keeps an eye on it
I have an Adu they're wonderful um and
um well I I'll come back to that um so
that that that's the only benefit that I
would see not to the public certainly
not to the housing situation um I
briefly want to respond to a couple of
comments that have been made uh my
colleague Ben Frost who I know well I
have tremendous respect for
um I I'm not an attorney but our town
attorney um has stated that this is
legal she's very conservative very
experienced in Municipal law um and this
this law of three unrelated has been
vetted um and but but even in terms of
what Ben says there is certainly a
compelling interest for the town of
Durham to have this ordinance in place
and it is by far the most effective
um I you know Alternatives that have
been proposed they just would not be
effective um some people say well why
don't you enforce the other laws you
know cars on lawns noise ordinance um
public drinking garbage um we try um it
still is often an issue but um I want to
give you an example as a as a planner
that um the value of having an
ordinance um that avoids a situation
that is going to be very problematic um
I used to be the planner in Rochester
New Hampshire and we had um we approved
a number of Home occupations for people
to have um car maintenance for their
homes to make a little extra money and
the the owners we we required it was
allowed under our home occupation
ordinance at least by some discretion
always said I will have one car at a
time always in my garage um always be
quiet no noise Etc and a number of these
home occupations were approved in in a
number of cases it just became a real
problem the property owner had multiple
cars they were on the lawn uh they had
the garage open they were noisy and it
was a an enforcement Nightmare and once
it is set up um it's it's very very
difficult to enforce and as um uh Jay
goose said we have a noise ordinance the
police will come this they're they're
gone they're inebriated they've gone
home it's virtually impossible to
enforce the the intelligent thing is to
have an ordinance that does not give an
opening to something that you know is is
going to be a problem um the uh you know
one question was asked is this anything
to do with morals with couples living
together absolutely not I assure you
that that is that is not the case that
is never
never been a consideration uh another
question was well families Buy in town
they know it's a University Town that's
true and they also trust their local
government will protect them protect
their quality of life and their property
values and they also know that we have
this three unrelated rule um and the the
town works very hard to manage trash
noise cars on Lots drunken behavior um
um so Durham Durham is proud to host the
University of New Hampshire it's an
outstanding uh top Public University
thousands of unh students live in our
town and in do New Market Portsmouth
summersworth and Rochester managing
student housing especially we're mainly
talking about single family houses in
neighborhoods is a a fundamental and
even an existential issue in our town
when when we learned about this proposal
people were terrified in our community
about how the devastating impact this
would have on Durham on Hanover on
Plymouth on Keane and to some degree on
Manchester um we are holding a tiger by
the tail we love our students but it the
situation causes numerous problems
evaluating the impacts is an ongoing
matter of discussion frequently
deliberated by the town Council the
planning board the Conservation
Commission the energy committee the
historic district commission and by our
housing task force and the staff we
delve into the Myriad details related to
student housing to maintain durm is a
beautiful diverse well-run Town while
also respecting the rights and concerns
of students we love our students student
housing is a major industry uh and
taxpayer in town uh the town approaches
the issue in good faith with much
analysis and input from the University
our partner landlords and residents
especially those who live in
neighborhoods this proposed law would
undermine that
process host communities are in the best
position to make these decisions unlike
Workforce housing where there is a huge
recognized need and countless challenges
to its development it doesn't pay for
itself we are wrestling with this how to
promote Workforce housing in an
expensive town like Durham um student
housing does not need an
assist they do just fine thank you very
much at at $1,400 a bed they're doing
just fine they do not need any help the
students do not need help the landlords
do not need help um um students rights
to housing are not being infringed upon
um student housing brings in millions of
dollars in tax revenues and revenue and
supports our local businesses
it would be impossible and foolish for
us to try to restrict this use um as has
been mentioned most St most uh housing
developments are rented by the bed
students can pay that um if a
three-bedroom apartment or H single
family house for students rents for
$4,000 say 1350 a bed um then um
families will never be able to go there
and the thing to keep in mind is within
a neighborhood and we have l lots of
neighborhoods primarily single family
but they wonderful mixed historic
neighborhoods as I say duplexes
triplexes other apartments um
one problem house will destroy a street
that's just the reality of it so you
know we can talk about in in very the
theoretical terms about rights um but
how about balancing the rights and again
one problem house will destroy a street
and our ordinances are not very helpful
and the fact of the matter is that
Durham and other communities have hit
upon the the simplest direct most
effective way to address that and that
is a maximum three related it doesn't
always work but it's extremely effective
there is a correlation in a house
between the number of students and the
likelihood of having problems the more
than students the more likely you'll
have problems with three it seems to be
kind of a magic number number in most
cases it works really well um and
um so um just a few more a few more just
a few more comments if I may um so
addressing undergraduate student life
off campus is a highly particular and
complicated issue it must be worked
through by each municipality based upon
the individual character of the school
and the community what is being proposed
is a very very blunt instrument which is
not attending at all to the particular
characteristics of the half a dozen
towns that wrestle with this every
single day adopting this amendment will
be damaging not only to Durham and the
other college towns U but also to the
colleges and our Flagship University UNH
in particular Our Town gown relationship
is excellent much of that's due to our
outstanding Town Administrator and a
series of of excellent uh presidents of
unh we've been very fortunate we have
excellent relations we communicate with
them at every level um and one of the
major issues is addressing student
housing um and we are in line we the
university supports our rule um and I
want to tell you that if this ordinance
goes through um that will damage UNH our
Flagship University because Town gown
relations will suff ER it will engender
ill will in the community many residents
longtime residents will be very angry
they'll be angry at unage they won't
shop downtown they'll they'll badmouth
UNH um and that will affect the
university image and brand is very
important and this will impact our
Flagship University's ability to recruit
faculty and students in the highly
competitive environment in which all
colleges are now operating the town of
Durham is highly engaged in addressing
the affordable housing crisis I serve as
staff to the Durham housing task force
whose mission it is to promote housing
options and affordable housing um and I
want to say I am also on the board of
the workforce Housing Coalition of the
Sea Coast of SE Coast New Hampshire so
I'm very this issue is very close to my
heart I've spoken about housing numerous
times but um and the the workforce
Housing Coalition is not taking a
position on this and I I am speaking as
myself not this is not for the workforce
Housing Coalition I bring that up only
because of my to show my commitment to
this issue um and I respect um the
representative from housing action um
but I I I firmly disagree um you know I
I enthusiastically support certain
thoughtful mandates from the state
regarding housing that are needed an Adu
statute was passed uh five or so years
ago and that was great that was a
mandate because communities were in my
opinion irresponsibly not allowing adus
adus are great you know it's not going
to hurt your neighborhood they're
well-managed and if your community is
not allowing them the state should come
in and make you do it the state did that
that was an excellent statute there's
another statute about adus taking that
further I applaud that effort that is
appropriate it's been vetted and
discussed with all the state
stakeholders um so as a um but this
proposal has in no is in no way
comparable this has not been vetted we
are the experts at Durham and Hanover
Plymouth and Kean nobody spoke to us
about it my understanding is two
landlords showed up at a public hearing
frankly two landlords who have had a
number of run-ins with the town um
because of of not respecting some of our
ordinances and we were not even aware
when this thing came forward so that was
very upsetting for us to learn about
this after the fact um as a professional
Town planner with over 30 years of
experience um I I do think that I am
somewhat of an expert in the housing
issue and I will assure you that this
proposal will not ass help our housing
situation it will undercut those efforts
again because of a single family house
rather than being attractive and having
opportunities for families um of Modera
income nobody will be able to compete
when when the rent is is $66,000 from
six students in there this is a
fundamental issue for Durham and for
other college
towns um please respect our community's
long-standing good faith efforts to deal
with this challenging local matter and
please direct important efforts toward
Workforce housing um in other areas that
will be effective and please find this
bill inexpedient to l legislate thank
you representative B thank you Mr chair
thank you for being here and testifying
um you spoke a little bit about how the
relationship between the the the school
and the town are very good correct I
mean but I'm looking at like this
resolution by the student Senate that
they put out last month and it literally
says at the end to condemn the tone of
the Town Council of Durham and claim
that the students are separate
residential Enclave of Durham and cannot
be
co-inhabit traditional residential
communities and it it says earlier in it
that they believe that you implying that
students in the town of Durham are
separate constituencies and do not
necess necessitate Equal Housing
considerations I guess what I'm saying
is like the student Senate opposes it or
is in favor of this but the town is
against it what if all the students
voted in town elections that ordinance
would go right
away uh well I I we welcome our students
to vote and we welcome them to sit on
Town boards uh there's some very young
people on the planning board and on the
Town Council now um we're very pleased
about um well you know I can't speak for
the person I I um I think that if um the
majority well this you know the majority
of students are probably are not
informed about the issue they're not
sensitive to um you know issues in
neighborhoods for families um you know I
I think that the officials at UNH would
certainly support us um and I think if
student many students who were
thoughtful um you know if they had an
opportunity to sit down and talk with me
and other Town officials and we could
talk about the issue uh I think many of
them would support the provisions we
have in place um you know I for whatever
reason I think some students probably
the president of the Senate some other
supporters um you know may feel some
alienation because there are this is a
big issue um we have had some projects
where there were student housing
proposed that there were that that
people were very upset about where a
great deal of student housing was
proposed in a new development close to a
neighborhood and I think there was some
alienation there but generally we have
excellent relations with students um
they see it differently you know most of
them are living in in student
developments are on campus they are not
attuned to the problem s and I live in a
single family house in Durham and I've
had people come by at 3: in the morning
screaming
inebriated um most students are
wonderful we love our students we are
our town will dry up would dry up
without UNH um but we are holding a
tiger by the tail we have to manage this
and um this is legal it is appropriate
where we are drawing the line at
families and they could be up to 10
people versus is unrelated and unrelated
when you have four or more not always
but in many cases in a single family
neighborhood when they're inebriated on
a Thursday Friday or Saturday night they
don't behave well it's oil and water
many of them are wonderful but the the
the odds of it happening with an
unrelated household which in Durham is
going to be undergraduate students is
vastly greater and isn't that what we do
in policy
we set our policy based on um costs and
benefits and probabilities um so yes
some families behave badly many students
behave wonderfully but there is a very
clear correlation and this is therefore
we could we believe its effective
policy okay follow up it it seems to me
the policy you put in place benefits 33%
at the expense to 66% of the residents
of your town well who is it
hurting student rents like the price of
housing U most students you know not
affected I'm on campus we have thousands
of of units in large student housing
developments that are wonderful um it's
mainly affecting people in houses in
neighborhoods and the landlords who wish
that they could rent to five or six kids
um I'm just not aware of many Stu you
know there's probably some students that
you know four or five of them would love
to rent a house in a neighborhood um you
know they could go to do there's many
other housing opportunities I think
those situations are rare also by the
way this has no effect on fraternities
and boarding houses does not that
they're they're not affected by this
ordinance represent
giv thank you
um you've mentioned several times uh
what you believe that the views of
students are and you mentioned earlier
during your
testimony that um you asked for input
from residents uh but did you ask for
input from student
organizations because it does seem to me
and here I speak as as someone uh who
was a graduate student um lived in a
neighborhood that was about half
families and half students in a a single
unit that had four students living
together and later on in a house uh that
had five people some of them working
some of them students living together
because that was the most workable and
affordable um uh type of housing that
that we could find so it it it does seem
to me that um the people who would be
harmed um uh by not passing this
amendment uh would not only be the
investors um but would also be those
students who need to find housing in
groups which students almost always do
if they need to live off campus so back
to to my question sorry for going on a
bit um did you ask for input from
student
organizations well our ordinance has
been in place for many years so we
haven't um you know needed to um have a
dialogue about it it's been in place and
it's function well but the dialogue that
is ongoing in the community is about
General zoning and housing issues and um
I you know I speak with students and
other stakeholders all the time members
of fraternity
uh people in houses um our certainly our
code enforcement officer does so you
know I think we have a pretty good sense
of of of the the world that we operate
in um and again it's it's everything is
a tradeoff so I I believe the very small
number of groups of four five or six
that would like to live together in a
house that cannot do that in Durham
versus the benefits of limiting three I
you know I just see the cost benefit
like this there's so many options for
students I know there's some students
that struggle that we have we have
homeless students in in Durham we have
students that are living in their cars
um which is very upsetting but that has
nothing to do that has to do with very
tragic family Dynamics nothing to do
with this but um the tradeoff seems
clear to us and there are so many
options again with adus um oncampus
housing um renting in do where they they
don't have this rule or New Market or
Rochester and in housing developments
off campus the ability to rent and over
may I do a followup sorry um wouldn't
the ability to rent and over be um
dependent upon Transportation which not
all students have right but there are
many options overall for
students but back to my original
question you mentioned during your
testimony that you have uh requested
input um and I don't know when you when
you were referring to whether it was
when you originally passed the ordinance
or more recently it sounds like more
recently you have been specifically
requesting input from residents you can
tell me if I'm wrong so when you did
that did you request input from from
students and I speak in reference to um
the student Senate resolution that um
representative Alexander
reference um well again the the input is
not regarding our because that is has
been in place a long time the input is
in my daily job um dealing with planning
zoning and housing people that come in
to talk with me um General issues when
we reach out to the broad Community all
the stakeholders including the UNH
officials and students undergraduate and
graduate so it nothing and then we also
our housing task force um has reached
out a lot has had a major Outreach
effort to stakeholders about housing in
general um we've gotten input from UNH
administrators Town employees
firefighters teachers um graduate
students um some undergraduates that
that we were able to contact so you know
I I I suspect probably many
undergraduate students from their point
of view if they learn about this
ordinance they'd say GE I don't like
that but it's not really affecting them
they probably don't are not sensitized
to the issue
um yeah many probably would not like it
just on the idea of it but again in
terms of cost benefit what's really
happening on the ground you know okay
thank you you have a question
representative Walsh thank you Mr chair
and I have three quick ones if that's
okay yep first one regarding this Senate
resolution anybody know how many of the
senators in UNH own
home I would guess none but you don't
have to answer that oh well I I probably
you know none of them on their own but
there's a there's a lot of historically
um undergraduate students when they come
to Durham usually as a freshman their
Savvy parent will buy a house and the
student I don't I think they have to
live on campus freshman year and now
sophomore year but they'll buy a house
at some point the child will live there
with roommates um and then the parent
may keep it or they'll sell it years
later usually at a pretty good profit um
that's one of the issues you know that's
one of the kinds of investors that we
have and as my next question I believe
it was mentioned but I just want to
clarify from my notes what year was the
uh ordinance and Durham adopt
uh I don't know I heard
70s
unrated three unrelated yeah 86 thank
you and I have one more um how many
other towns or cities in New Hampshire
have the three unrelated ordinance yeah
that's a great question um I don't know
exactly um the representative that
presented this I think she mentioned
eight municipalities I don't but I don't
know that U I do know that um Handover
I'm I'm often in contact with planners
in Hanover Plymouth and Keane to a
lesser extent um Manchester um comparing
notes about the ordinances and policies
that they have to manage this issue so I
it's a little different in every
Community but everybody wrestles with it
in their own way
thank you okay that it okay um I only
have one comment I know that there's a
lot of colleges and univers and a couple
universities in New Hampshire and I'm
wondering why Durham and UNH are the
only ones that showed up to even say
anything today well we have had some
email connection with um I think you got
a letter from somebody might have been
the town manager from
hover um and um that that I I don't know
you know people are busy they we we've
had some email exchanges
um Durham was pretty vocal in our email
maybe they assumed that we were taking
the lead on it I don't know okay thank
you Mr chair oh one more Yeah question
to the chair could it be because this is
heard
maybe okay all right well thank you very
much and we got one card left Audrey
thank you very much can I something out
um should
here
oppose last but not least we saved the
you I I I wasn't necessarily intending
to speak today but I I think I need to U
my name is Audrey Klein I'm the code
enforcement officer in Durham uh I'm
also the building inspector uh the
health
inspector um and I don't catch dogs but
I'm waiting for that so I'm responsible
for all the zoning enforcement all the
building code enforcement um and health
uh Health laws in Durham uh I want to
just start out by giving you some
information based on some of the
questions I heard earlier uh and if you
have any other questions for me I'd be
happy to answer them um so these are
kind of some factual backup to some of
the
questions um one of the questions that a
representative asked was wasn't didn't
Durham uh wasn't Durham applying the
three unrelated uh illegally already
because of the accessory dwelling unit
with the single family dwelling and uh
the state law that read the state law
6747 two for uh accessory dwelling units
um number four states that any Municipal
regulation applicable to single family
dwelling shall also apply to the
combination of principal dwelling and
Adu so it's permitted in the uh recent
Adu regulation that the current laws uh
can apply to both units and that's
exactly what happens in Durham today is
that the three unrelated regulation was
was in place for single families and
therefore it is in place for the Adu
plus the single family I just wanted to
make it clear that we're not breaking
any laws by enforcing that at this
point
um I wanted to uh also back up what
Michael was saying well we don't
regulate by who's sleeping in what bed
or how many beds there are you can have
a a one-bedroom apartment and have three
unrelated people we don't have any
regulation or anything to think or say
about that at all and so it's not a
matter of bedroom having said that
there's no distinction between a bedroom
and any other room in a house um unless
you're talking about a house on a
private septic system where the system
by Dees calls out how many bedrooms that
house is allowed to have if you're on
Town Water and Sewer uh any room is a
bedroom and I've seen it many times that
in a traditional home the formal living
room and the formal dining room are now
bedrooms because people are using them
as bedrooms so I don't know how we would
even identify how many bedrooms a house
had um in this uh proposal um because I
sometimes fall asleep in the bathtub but
it you know is that a bedroom I I don't
know um going to the fire code that that
Ben Frost was discussing the fire code
is uh only um restricted to no less than
200 square fet per person so my my home
is 1500 square fet that could hold seven
individuals I can't say I haven't
sometimes had seven relatives at my
house but I I I know that that young
people have very active social lives
they have friends and partners and seven
people really means 20 people in my
experience in a lot of cases on many
nights uh in
Durham
um let me I I was taking notes as we're
going so you have to excuse me a minute
um an unrelated household uh the
question was what is Durham's definition
household um of two of more people
related within a second degree of
kinship by civil law or marriage or
adoption or foster care uh I don't know
what the civil law is for unmarried
couples living together whether they're
considered married or not but the second
degree of uh relation is spouse children
parents brothers sisters half Brothers
half Brothers grandchildren and
grandparents
um the third level would include Aunts
Uncles nieces nephews great-grandparents
so there is definition for what the
levels of kinship are uh and Durham's
Durham's ordinance says with the second
degree of
kinship um as as been mentioned uh there
is a Supreme Court case
that has uh the decision that it is
legal to restrict people by their
familial or related status and that is
the fiser versus New Hampshire State
Building Code review uh case which as
was in Durham uh there were two cases
one was very early on I think in the 50s
but then again in the in the 80s and the
Supreme Court did rule that it was uh
not discriminatory to have the
regulation that that Durham had at the
time
um to go on to some uh just a couple of
points that aren't in strict law since I
do the enforcement I actually see uh I
see a lot of other situations that
haven't been discussed here because
we've been talking about the word
students and um just like with any
enforcement there's a
prioritization system that one has to
follow because we only have certain
amount of resources so if you look at
the estate Trooper on the highway most
people people are going 65 70 maybe a
little over the speed limit but that
state trooper has to look at who he's
going to or she is going to pull over
and they're going to look at the car
that's swerving in between between lanes
speeding throwing trash out the window
or other activities that raise it above
the average violation so to speak and
that's true with the enforcement that we
do for the um activities that happen in
these three unrelated or any other
property in town
um if there isn't some impact that's
impacting or visible then I probably w't
even know that there's three unrelated
or not so I'm enforcing the most
impactful violations of the ordinance
and that's not always students we have
some that are there was mentioned
there's you know there's families that
fight um there's families that have
trashy Lawns and park on their lawns um
so it's a matter of the level of the
violation not who lives there so we
we're we're not
focusing the regulation on students it
is true that young people are out there
the first time probably away from home
they need some guard reels to understand
what it means to live on their own in a
community um and we talk with them
regularly on a on a uh informal basis
uh every semester every every year when
when new young people move into town we
talk with them about what the
expectation is for their trash for their
parking for their activities in town and
uh and before it ever gets to any kind
of formal enforcement um many
opportunities for them to learn um what
the expectations are and often when I'm
enforcing households that are not
occupied by young people they also have
to come into compliance so it it it just
so happens that the the young people
households are still learning how to do
it so they tend to be a more out of
compliance on a regular basis than some
other
households um okay I'd be happy to take
any questions any
questions representative band thank you
Mr chair are you telling me that you
more strictly enforce student housing
than opposed to other residents of
Durham no I think I was saying that I
don't more strictly enforce them that I
actually enforce them I enforce the
level of violation not necessarily the
individual people that live in the house
okay and then my other question is we
talked a little bit about um order of
kinship third degree so you're talking
like Aunt uncle that sort of thing is
third degree
kinship so that third degree out based
on your Definition of kinship third
degree kinship if there's four four
people that are related within three
degrees they wouldn't be allowed to live
together because you would have so say
if like an aunt wanted to adopt their
nephew or niece and have them live in
the same house as them otherwise they'd
be homeless based on your ordinance they
wouldn't be allowed to do that or are
you allowed to un are you allowed to
enforce the ordinance for students but
not the ordinance for the aunt that
wants to adopt their nephew I guess I'm
wondering like do you discriminate do
you do you enforce one ordinance for one
group of people over an ordinance for
another group of people in town that's
what I'm asking no I I I approach the
enforcement of the vi of the ordinances
and the violation based on the level of
impact um or the amount of violation
going on given the uh amount of time I
have to enforce so if if there was a
household with an aunt who's adopting
her best friend's child for instance uh
unless that household is
also um very visibly violating the
ordinance first of all I would never
know second of all they can have up to
two unrelated people so in that case
that wouldn't necessarily make it a
violation um that's helpful yeah thank
you representative
Gibbs thank you um
uh just a a comment first of all um and
that is that um someone who was in the
POS process of adopting a child that
would come under both federal and state
familial status law so um that would
also be helpful there uh but the
question that I wanted to ask and thank
you for taking it um you mentioned
earlier that uh the three unrelated rule
could legally be applied to the main
unit plus the Adu and I'm not sure um
how that would how that would work um
that is suppose I um rent a house with a
roommate who is not related to me and uh
then there's an Adu and two roommates
who are unrelated rent that Adu so that
would be two unrelated people in the
house and two unrelated people in the
Adu um would that violate your three
unrelated uh ordinance or not yes it
would our ordinance um and the state law
the Adu state law uh which coincides
with our ordinance says that the single
family dwelling with an Adu is in many
ways treated like a single family
dwelling you don't have to have a larger
lot size there's many things that you
would be required to have if you had two
separate dwelling units that the Adu
regulation the state regulation doesn't
re require because the purpose of it was
to make them as readily available as
possible therefore not making two
separate units so our local law
coincides with the ability to have to uh
to apply the three unrelated to those
two units as one as one unit so that
would that would be in
violation
followup I just wanted to mention that
that appears what you just um uh
specified um that appears to contradict
some of the earlier testimony that uh
indicated that the ordinance would not
be applied in that way so I don't know
which which governs but I just wanted to
mention
that thank you as the code enforcement
officer I have to say that I'm 100%
correct thank
you okay all set okay thank you very
much thank you that concludes all the
testimony
wait so we're going to close the hearing
now um on um 527 um Germain um n Germain
Amendment and um okay thank you
represent so we had noticed in executive
session we have three members absent so
I think um I'm G to hold off on that for
a week or so um I'm
thinking I know representative Walsh is
ready to vote but I don't think I'm
ready to vote yet um so if you need a
sub for the day of the executive session
feel free to let us know and we'll
appoint a sub um but I will hold off I'm
thinking either a session day during a
lunch that everyone's here so make it
easy or or a Friday but um I will let
the committee know does anybody while we
notice the exact does anybody have any
preliminary um things to say about
either of the two
bills something for any of us to think
about anything
I mean we're in EXA we're in exact
technically I'm not going to have any
votes but if you'd like to
exact
okay
um okay so I'm going to hold off on the
exact and we'll have this another day
everyone